Mà lất cảm, hình thành sau này nữa
vì vì nhất là nếu như các bạn
không túng điểm bọc các bạn muốn
mà một ngày gần vì tôi nghĩ là các bạn
có thể chúng ta tham gia chúng ta học như thế này
bân khảnh nói chúng ta có thể chồng sau rồi thì thêm nhận đi kinh thức trong một tình chủ các nửa
bởi vì tụt tế các kỳ ngày học là này thì nó có tính liên năng các bạn
tôi là vì dụng như bảo ngon tị tính đăng
hồi mình ngàn tinh viên cút tế, mình nhìn tinh đăng tinh đăng tinh
mình đăng tinh đăng tinh đăng tinh đăng tinh đăng tinh đăng tinh
để là chúng ta không làm những công việc mà tương tương qua với nhau
và một cái nhẹ học thì nó có thể có rất nhiều là một cái nhau
tụi tinh